it's 5:00 a.m. and we're on our way to
Guanabara a suburb of the Cuban capital
Havana
Joell Montero Herrera and his wife unit
sir are rebuilding their home that's not
the only big change here six months ago
Joelle started his own one-man taxi
business it's now six o'clock
what's your oil doing up so early we
asked actually says he's off to a late
start he's broken a headlight normally
he'd be on the road by 4:00 a.m. while
he's waiting for the Sun to come up you
need to make some some more strong
coffee of course I'd rather he stay home
she says but he has to work I'm pregnant
and I can't work so he's got to manage
for us all before their five-year-old
son is even out of bed Joelle tells you
need some good bye it's time for work
joella's taxi a 1955 Chevrolet classic
the cab cost him the equivalent of
11,000 euros Joelle borrowed the money
from his father-in-law there aren't that
many taxis out yet he tells us it's
gonna be a good day and soon enough he's
already picked up his first passengers
heading for town Joelle's new enterprise
is only possible because of economic
reforms in Cuba that have made it
possible for small private businesses to
sprout up
what will Cuba be like in five years we
ask no idea he says and in a decade
absolutely no idea he says Joelle tells
us the world is changing not just in
Cuba across the world things are
developing and there are also some
things that are getting worse
he says here in our country things are
no different there's a lot of
uncertainty no one knows what could
happen tomorrow hopefully he says our
exchange rates will improve oil explains
that Cuba has two currencies the Cuban
peso used every day by the vast majority
of Cubans and the convertible peso used
often by foreign tourists to buy luxury
goods he says on a good day he can make
1,100 regular pesos but figure in fuel
costs in the exchange rate and he's down
to ten convertible pesos and profits
that's about ten US dollars which means
to make a living
Joell drives about fourteen hours a day
six days a week still he's proud of his
work and his car
it's a rolling Museum in other countries
these cars are seen as a copy as class
except people keep for their own
pleasure here it's our means of
transport our work and our income
thanks to these old American cars we
have work the cars are sturdy they're
the only ones that would last this long
Michael wanted
we leave Joella Havana for now and head
off 200 kilometers to the west to Pinar
del río province the world's most famous
tobacco region we're here to visit
Francisco Jose Prieto and his father
Pancho they are members of a farmers
collective their land has been in the
family for generations Francisco Jose
shows us where the leaves are hung to
dry he says the system makes more space
for the women to do their work
it is mostly women who cure the tobacco
leaves most of them have been added for
many years their work is especially
needed during the high season from
January to March once the leaves are
cured
the Cuban state will buy up the entire
harvest and recently the state has
started paying more than it used to for
workers like 72 year-old Marita Alvarez
that means higher wages good news for
her and her sizeable family she says she
always hoped her children would go to
university and all three managed to do
it now all her grandchildren are at
university of course she's very happy
about that now everything here is better
she says it used to be good work and
work and all you'd get was a few cents
now she says you really see the results
of your labor
Mirta tells us she gets paid twice a
month the last time she gets 665 Cuban
pesos even though work had to be
canceled a few times because of rain you
couldn't make that much before Cuba
cigars are next to sugar the islands
most important export good employees
here say they like working for Francisco
Jose Prieto
many have come back again and again for
decades to help out at harvest time the
oldest of them is in his mid-70s
Prieto says his workers are happy
voluntarily that one before they see a
happy man is one who gets up in the
morning and wants to go to work and when
his work is over wants to go home
everything else depends on personal
happiness and a stable family life what
about you we asked I'm a happy man he
says create those estate is successful
and foreign tourists come here to welter
Abajo to see where Cuba's world-famous
cigars come from many of them cigar
aficionados themselves and many of them
from Germany tour guide tells us group
in German that these leaves are used for
pipe tobacco and cigarettes some of the
visitors have been to Cuba before well
that's why I come here every two years
because it's beautiful here people are
nice there's good music and good company
what about the tobacco we asked Cuban
tobacco is the best out there 99.9
percent of the time we only smoke Cuban
cigars they still bunch all the tobacco
leaves together with a kind of needle
like 100 years ago good the people have
honest work I hope that they're well
paid that there's a minimum wage we
asked another worker Gladys Diaz what
she has to say about that
I'm still young she says but I did get
to know capitalism for a few years
before things changed when I retired I
came back here and I'm doing quite well
here Francisco Jose pays as well we get
to take meal breaks they bring us coffee
and cold water to drink it's really good
no think I feel like I had a Largo Oh
Wally yeah no choc jacket okay good
one of us here on Francisco Jose tells
us Cuba is moving along very well even
if the changes have been slow in coming
he says they are very much for the
better he says you just have to go out
into the streets to see the differences
everything that's cropping up all the
new private businesses that people are
building every day there's something new
that's changed our lives
I can't be a little too long you know
you it really has changed it's gotten
much better one change that would be
hard for me though is if my son doesn't
take over the farm this is our lives
work you lunchtime it's a break best
enjoyed in the shade the workers wait
for the Sun to go down a bit more before
they get back to their posts
the highway back to Havana is nearly
empty in town at a dance show we meet up
again with taxi owner Joe L his wife who
Nitze and some friends of the couple
Joelle has even taken the afternoon off
the for ride in Joelle's Chevy along the
Malecon Havana's popular coastal route
vasin the rabble we come here to drink a
beer sit in the Sun and enjoy the cool
breeze he says to chat a little then
forget about our troubles and our work
for a little while you'll be unknown at
all what kind of troubles we ask joy
says he's worried about getting their
home rebuilt before the baby comes
then there's the car if anything breaks
it's a tough situation there are no
replacement parts available your needs
is thinking even further ahead maybe in
three or four years when we're better
off we can have another kid she says but
maybe not our living space is already
very cramped no more sea soil tells us
before buying his taxi he was an
economist for the Cuban state for seven
years and at the end he says what could
I do
oh now I'm self-employed so that I can
support myself and my family
the four go for a stroll through
Havana's old town popular among foreign
tourists
it's expensive here Joelle says how
expensive we asked well for us it's
super expensive he says if you take our
national peso and exchange it for the
convertible peso it's clear we can't
afford it here miss areas for foreign
tourists so why do they come here most
like to look around he says that's all
we can do why not
the friends are happy to be here even if
it's just for a little daydreaming
you